من راه في ليله صوت الارض اعتقد ان الفنان
السعودي الراحل طلال مداح قد عاد من جديد
الى الحياه فالشبه الكبير بينهما يكاد
يكون متطابقا الى حد لا يصدق عيسى التركي
الرجل الذي اصبح حديث العالم العربي على
مواقع التواصل عقب ظهورها على مسرح الفنان
محمد عبده في ليله صوت الارض بسبب الشبه
الكبير بينه وبين الفنان الراحل طلال مداح
وفي الليله التاريخيه لتكريم الفنان
السعوديه الراحل كان لابد من لفته تبقى في
الذاكره هذه اللفته التي كانت من خلال
حضور رائع للكثير من الفنانين ومحبي صاحب
الحنجره الذهبيه الجميع دون استثناء عاش
لحظات دهشه بسبب الشبه الذي لفت نظرهم بين
التركي ومداح واليوم في صباح العربيه
سنكون عن قرب مع الشبيه الذي اعاد صوره
طلال مداح للحضور بين الجمل
اول شيء بدنا نعرف متى اكتشفت هذا الشبه
الكبير بينك وبين الراحل طلال
بشبه هذا جت فتره من الفترات تقريبا قبل
17 سنه او 18 سنه تقريبا
كل ما اجي اخرج في اي محفل ولا في يعني
مناسبه متعلقه بالاصحاب الناس يعني تبدا
ايش تتقرب لي وتتصور معاي انت شبيه طلال
مداح انت شبه طلال مداح فما كنت يعني كنت
متوقع انه هذا الشبح حيكون بالحجم هذا
يعني
طيب استاذ عيسى تمنيت انه يكون عندك صوت
جميل قريب لصوت الراحل المبدع طلال مداح
ومثلا قد تمثل دور من اعماله اعمال
مستقبليه مثلا والله صوت طلال مداح اجمع
عليه الجميع يعني على اساس انه كان موهبه
من الله سبحانه وتعالى للفنان الكبير رحمه
الله عليه كان يجذب قلوب الناس كثيرا يعني
كنت الواحد كان يتمنى بصراحه انه يكون
عنده صوت طالع المداح
هذه طبعا مو بيدي الواحد يعني طيب سيدي
عيسى انتشر لك بقوه جدا فيديو وانت تتحدث
مع ابنه الراحل طلال مداح شو اللي دار
بينكم وكيف كان شعورها بس شافتك والله
ابنه الفنان طلال مدح نغم اصرت على مقابله
بحيث كنت اتحاشى انا على اساس الموقف اللي
صار خفت
مؤثر بيني وبينك
ولما قابلتني انصدمت وانبهرت من الشبه
اللي بيني وبين والدها يعني طيب بس لدرجه
انها قالت نسخه يعني
بس انا كمان
بدي حاولت تعمل اضافات
لتاكد وتزيد هذا الشبح يعني هل النظ
ارات اللي انت حاطتهم كانت مقصوده انه
تكون شبيهه بالتي كان يستعملها الراحل
طلال مداح لا والله بالعكس هذه انا من
زمان معي النظاره وبيني وبينك وفي نظاره
ثانيه يعني اطاره ثانيه تختلف
يعني نفس الاطار قريب من الاطار لو ارد
عليك دور في فيلم يحكي عن الراحل طلال
مداح توافق انك اتمثل
[موسيقى]